a little out of juice only 42 kilometers
range
left and that's why we need to come here
when jeff shaw needs to get his car
refueled
he doesn't go to a gas station and not
always one that charges electric
vehicles
instead he goes to a battery swap
station
in about five minutes he can have his ev
battery replaced with a fully charged
one that has a driving range of up to
260 miles more than enough for the 42
year olds daily commute to work
and that's way faster than the the gas
station experience i think
let's go shaw is driving a neo
a rising star in china's electric
vehicle market
once on the brink of bankruptcy the
startup was bailed out by the government
and has since seen its shares soar
at the end of 2020 neo is worth more
than general motors
ranking as the world's fifth most
valuable automaker
and that has a lot to do with its
batteries
in other words a neo customer doesn't
need to buy the vehicle with the battery
and so far it's the only automaker in
china to do this
many investors say neo's commercial
strategy is revolutionary
so as tesla speeds ahead as the market
leader in china
should it be worried
the gas station's on the big screen and
there's there's the battery pack getting
swapped out
neo isn't the first electric vehicle
company to try switching out the battery
you have the the choice of a battery
pack swap
which is faster than you can fill a gas
tank in 2013
tesla demoed its battery swap technology
and the following year built a trial
swap station in california
later dropped the project saying drivers
weren't interested in swapping their
batteries
because the supercharging stations were
fast enough
even as these charges can take more than
75 minutes to fully power a car
we'll be expanding the supercharged
network quite
substantially over time
despite tesla pulling the plug on
battery swaps its chinese rival neo is
moving ahead with the technology
the concept of battery swapping is
fairly straightforward
the actual actually implementing it and
making a viable business out of it
is quite a bit more complicated sam
abiel summit is a car analyst who has
been watching the ev industry for more
than a decade
batteries are single most expensive
component in an electric vehicle
but the problem is batteries are also
still in a rapid stage of development
and so to date manufacturers have been
reluctant to
standardize anything but neo is choosing
to standardize the battery
so while most electric vehicles have
battery packs that are uniquely designed
for specific models and are built into
the cars
neo has one battery pack that fits into
all its models
and this battery costs about ten
thousand seven hundred dollars
so that means neo's cheapest model which
costs around fifty two thousand dollars
gets a twenty percent discount if buyers
choose to skip the battery
the company said a third of its
customers are buying cars without the
battery
tesla and neo they have taken some some
different approaches to
the business model i think battery
swapping would certainly make neo very
competitive to tesla and to other
companies
for a flat fee of about a hundred fifty
dollars a month neo drivers can get six
battery replacements at more than 160
battery swap stations across china
when you drive or these are gasoline
vehicles their service
come to the end or when or the dealer
delivery car to you
but for neo it's very different
experience
neo drivers also have other battery
options like charging at home
or using an app to request a charging
track to show up
but its services and stations in china
fall far short of what's needed to
convince the world's largest evm market
to uptake battery swap vehicles
just compare the number of neos battery
swap stations to tesla's supercharging
stations in the country
and the more than 2 000 stations it has
worldwide
and this is where the government comes
into play battery swap
now is getting more attention right
looking into the policy uh support
behind it
xiugong is an auto consultant based in
shanghai
he says in the long run government
policy will likely determine how the ev
industry in china develops
beijing already has a 2035 goal for
broad eevee adoption in the country
battery swapping is getting a push this
year for the first time the technology
was mentioned in china's annual policy
blueprint
there's also a subsidy that seems
designed to help neo
consumers who purchase battery swap
vehicles with a minimum driving range of
250 miles
can receive about three thousand five
hundred dollars in subsidies
however electric vehicles without
battery swaps can only qualify if priced
below forty six thousand dollars
tesla had to cut the price of its model
3 in china by 10
to meet that threshold this type of
support has persuaded other chinese
automakers to signal that they too could
adopt the technology
bashu says they'll take a critical mass
of automakers to commit
before china runs in battery swaps you
can think of it it could be like a
mobile
or how to chevron type they build the
swapping
station they provide a different type of
batteries you know
big size small size to fit into
different vehicles
how's the stream factory but beijing
isn't only supportive of neo
we want to very much say thank you and
appreciation for
the shanghai government and the support
about one year after tesla started
building its gigafactory in shanghai
it started delivering model 3 sedans in
china
far outpacing the sales of neo vehicles
we tend to make continue making a
significant investment
and increasing the investment in china
neo's still playing catch-up but jeff
shaw is betting on the future of the
chinese startup
so much so that he bought shares of the
company
neo is absolutely in the front line of
our state of art
it's more than brand it's more than a
vehicle